je peux pas j'ai eu l'idée du siècle
encore chaussure à son pied on emploie
des gens qui vont porter les chaussures
de nos clients tu connais des gens qu'on
papier
je compte sur toi fred anniversaire de
ta soeur est ce que quelqu'un mais bien
j'ai donc lu ce message vous ne savez un
peu compliqué pour vous en fait c'est
gelé pour et je devrais leur serrer la
nuit est ce que je pourrais avoir un
petit but avec mon petit peu d'argent
[Musique]
il a vu la vie qu'ils mènent leur donne
une leçon
oliphant salies
on n'a plus d'argent ils veulent nous
foute reprise pardon
soit caché à marseille un truc que vous
a jamais fait de votre vie on fait venir
travailler bon c'est pas venir comme
j'en ai pas de diplômes parce que je
suis quelqu'un d'autodidacte ces pays
combien ce livre de 100 euros c'est par
semaine c'est ça non par jour comme
francis cabrel il a appris la guitare
tout seul le mois ce business
et dans ce cas c'est peut-être quelque
chose pour vous mais il ya le véhicule
de fonction et je serai pas déçu
oui t'as jamais été là à vous avez
manqué de rien si tu parle d'argent non
c'est toute chose dont on avait dit un
peu pas
[Musique]
est-ce que je donnerais pour voir ça
enfin bon ça ça va les courbes
je pense qu'on va beaucoup apprendre de
cette expérience et
on espérait ce qui se passe je veux
c'est sûr que c'est vraiment porter goss
que tu fais ça